foreign
what's up
hey how are you thanks for taking my
call of course what's up
so how do I stop enabling my husband so
that he can step up without relying on
me to pick up the slide
tell me more
so we've been married for about two and
a half years okay
um we now have two kids uh two little
babies and
um he has
um he will not keep a job he doesn't
know what he wants to do
doesn't want to work this any job so
he's working no job
correct
and he's got two little babies at home
and he's got a wife that means you're
having to keep the lights on and the
rent paid right yes
I don't mean to be rude but this guy's
pretty lame
foreign
I I totally understand I don't know what
job I want to do I don't want to work
the perfect job whatever but dude get a
job at McDonald's you got a bills to pay
your little kids
um was this is this the guy you married
or is there a bait and switch that
happened here
let's kind of explain that a little bit
with the bait and switch
has he always been a guy that's got a
scheme he's like and then I'm gonna buy
a duplexes and then I'm Gonna Get Rich
has he always been that guy
um or was he a really hard worker then
he had baby number one and he just hit a
wall and then he quit and then he kind
of stumbled and fumbled around and then
you had baby two
and he just kind of this kind of taking
over him like a like an illness
no
no in the middle
we actually met and married within like
three or four months so it's kind of all
kept like catching up to me now
um
all right so yeah
um so during that time he had worked
with family
um odd jobs handyman kind of work
um so nothing
exactly yes
what's kind of the promise of yeah I
think I want to do military or I think I
want to do this I want to do that
um this is what I'm going to do
um he he always comes up with good plans
um or
at least it sounds and try to come up
with a good plan but it's terrible at
following through
can I ask a question this is me I want
to throw a dart up against a wall
and and you'd be happy to say like nope
missed that one
how okay either one of two things got an
alcohol problem or some sort of
substance abuse problem or
his mom's still involved
his mom oh my gosh
are you for real
very very serious yeah
do you all live with them
um so we've been for a lot of last year
do you all still live in the same town
we do
so what role does Mom play in your life
I try to keep
we still visit her she's she babysits
the kids once a week
um I'll try to kind of keep up
boundaries what is he doing what is your
husband doing during the week
during the week yeah
um he sits at home
doing what
I have no idea
how do you have you sat down and looked
at him and said what do you do during
the day
uh I have a few times and it's usually
odd that on the phone watch TV take a
nap
and what is your response to this
uh before I would try to encourage him
to start a hobby and maybe find get a
job
and help for finding a career I would I
would encourage him to
um to study different we are nowhere
near career at this point
foreign
a seventh grade boy
you made a seventh grade boy whose mommy
still helps him
make sure his underwear is clean
and his mommy is still directing traffic
for him and his little girlfriend
who happens to be his wife and the
mother of his two kids and the
professional what do you do for a living
uh if I'm self-employed uh I am I am a
hair stylist and I manage an office
awesome absolutely oh so cool two jobs
and mother of two
um
and it's not as though he's like like
you all have sat down and planned this
out and he's a stay-at-home dad and he
takes care of all the laundry and all of
the dishes and make sure dinner's ready
when you get home none of that's
happening is that right
we I tried to earlier this year when we
moved into the home we're currently in
um I sat down with him and I said
um if this is if this is what you want
if you want to be a stay-at-home dad I
can make that work but if if you're
going to do that then you know his list
of you know cooking cleaning taking care
of the babies
if we're going to switch roles then we
need to do it
I guess as equally as possible and then
did he call his Mommy and say
she's being mean again she wants me to
do dishes and Mom said oh hell no no
baby amman's gonna be doing dishes
that's women's work is that what
happened well
he was kind of on board she was on my
side at the beginning of this year as as
long as I've never disagreed with what
she wants oh my gosh this is such a
wreck okay I'm just gonna stop you Nina
I'm just gonna stop you yep all of the
things you've tried have involved him
getting him to do things
that's not working
the only move you have left is to take
care of you
okay
um I don't know that your quote unquote
enabling him as much as enabling him
would be like you buy him alcohol I mean
you're allowing him to live in your
house which I guess is some sort of
enabling but I don't view it as enabling
so much as
this is not the life you thought you'd
be living two kids in Fair
this is madness
it's Madness and I know you probably
feel sometimes like am I crazy no you're
not crazy this is insane
your husband is completely bumming out
on you
and it's as as a husband and father of
two myself it's despicable and it's
gross and I would tell him so do his
face if he was sitting right here it's
embarrassing
okay you don't deserve this your kids
don't deserve this and God said he
doesn't deserve this he deserves a
better life than the one he's waking up
every day and choosing to live
okay here's the the hard part about that
you can't make him stop that life
all you can do is deal with you
and probably for the first time in a
while
I want you
to go get a hotel
to go spend a half day whatever you need
to do and y'all I know you can't afford
it I know things are tight right now
because you have a bum for a husband who
won't get a job
um but
I want you to uh
sit down with a piece of paper with a
notebook go to Walmart get it for 99
cents
and just write down here's what I need
here's the life that I want
I want someone who helps who has a job
who helps with the kids who is a partner
in this whole thing not that is waiting
to transition from one mother to another
mother
which is what he's doing he's got two
moms right
when I get home I need this when I get
home I will not do this
I need a husband who is working and
helping or I need a husband who is a
full-time stay-at-home dad who is
plugged all the way in I've got several
friends who have stay-at-home husbands
they're amazing they're busting their
butts man it's wild how good they are at
it
um but it is they're all in and
top of that list
his mom does not get a vote any sort of
input whatsoever
tell him you are not married to his mom
he needs to break up with his mother
because if he still wanted to live in
her house he shouldn't have married you
he shouldn't have slept with you and had
two kids
that ship has sailed right
she doesn't get a vote anymore
and you're trying to keep boundaries and
keep her happy and make sure you don't
cross her those days have to come to an
end because those things are coming at
the expense of your soul
right
yes
you're carrying too much sister
so
what you're describing and sitting down
and
need
um that actually happened
uh twice in the last two months okay
um
the first time I actually I sat down and
I told him what I wanted
it actually is mostly through text
because he doesn't like to have
conversations in person listen that's
got to stop electronic communication is
the absolute worst way to communicate
something this serious here's where you
are
this marriage is not even on life
support this marriage is about to be
pronounced dead
and then you get to choose how long you
want to play married until he moves on
to some other
woman who's going to support him or make
him feel loved because my wife don't
make me feel loved no more in between
waking up and having Bush tall boys and
Dr Pepper for breakfast and playing
fortnite
and then going back to bed right and so
he's gonna find somebody else
or his mom is gonna whatever or or you
are gonna find somebody else you're
gonna find somebody at work that's
actually kind and treats you with
dignity and respect and you're going to
end up violating your own values
to this thing is on life support as it
is so it's not time to like dance around
the edges anymore it's time to go and
turn all the lights on and say
um you you had a here's what I want
here's what I need
did you add a or what statement to that
I added an
and I did and
um he did leave uh when it was kind of
contingent on a job and he
woke up and decided he wasn't going so I
said okay there's the there's the or
leave you made that decision so I piled
his things by the door and he left okay
um and then in less than 24 hours it was
no I need you please let me come back
home I don't have anywhere to go
and I told him I was like nope there's
your mom's or
um shelters or anywhere else and he he
always manages to talk himself himself
back in no no no no no
you he doesn't manage to talk himself
back in you allow it
true
you allow it
is he even on the rent I mean is he even
on the lease here
he is yes
okay so he's got a legal claim to his
own house right
yes and he's got a legal claim to his
own children right
right yeah
and so you're you're a little 24
basically you're giving him like a a
timeout
foreign
and he's probably been getting little
timeouts and slaps on his hand his whole
life
and like the great Chuck pollen hook
says your life is ending one minute at a
time
and maybe no one's ever told you this
but you're worth more than your husband
is treating you right now
and you're worth more than working two
jobs coming home seeing his feet propped
up and him looking at you going hey the
kid's diaper needs to be changed what's
for dinner
foreign
is that how you grew up did you see that
growing up
no
complete opposite okay
we were raised to be uh very independent
and to work hard and
um
and I did see a consistent family my bad
uh self-employed very hard worker my mom
took care of there's several of us kids
and they worked as a really great team
and I knew I wouldn't have that exactly
because you know you're never going to
have picture perfect of what you think
but
you didn't expect this yeah we're near
yeah so
um I've said this on the show before and
I stand by this
um
I think we often
we often
take the word infidelity and we we too
narrowly Define it into are you having
sex with somebody other than me
I think infidelity I think Fidelity I
think commitment to is much broader than
body parts and sex
Fidelity is I'm all in on this thing
and you're all in on this thing
and so I would characterize what's
happening as infidelity
he's taking advantage of you
and there's two kids in the mix too and
they are watching oh this is how dads
are supposed to act
this is how marriage works this is what
mom looks like
and I'm not telling you for a second to
divorce the guy I can't do that I
wouldn't do that that's for you
I'm not telling you to kick him out I'm
telling him I'm telling you
you focusing on him trying to get him to
change his life is not working it hasn't
worked it's not gonna work
the only thing you can focus on moving
forward is here's what I need and here's
my or what statement
and you know what I'm not I'm I'm taking
the two kids and we're gonna leave
or if I mean if he's walks out the door
I don't think you can legally keep him
out of his own home but if you if he
chooses to leave cool and goes back to
his mommy's house
but this whole thing man it's a mess and
it it starts and ends with you
deciding I'm worth more than this
and I guess it also starts and ends with
him deciding to to stop dishonoring his
wife and stop dishonoring his children
to stop dishonoring himself and get up
and be an active participant in this
home
because the kids are suffering you're
suffering and he's suffering and enough
is enough is enough I'm heartbroken for
you
the three-month coveted romance isn't
turning out to be what you thought it
was going to be
um maybe it's time for one more this is
the way this will be
I'm gonna pay to get out of this lease
and I'm out
I won't make that call for you but you
get some people in your life that you
can sit down and work this through
stick to your boundaries you're worth
them